welcome to another ideas that matters
conversation I'm very excited to have my
guest Jonathan B here who has produced
an incredibly high production almost
gorgeous uh video series you could say
on Renee Gerard somebody who I read back
in graduate school and I was very
interested to see that somebody's doing
work that not only is competent but also
shows an appreciation for let's call it
the relevance of Renee Gerard's ideas
and Jonathan has a I'm going to let him
introduce himself in just a moment but
um I you know we've had some
conversations I got to know you first
through watching these you know just
Stellar uh videos this series
interpreting Gerard exegit of Apocalypse
a seven-part series and and these are
lengthy videos these are not you know 5
minute 10 minute 20 minute each of them
I think the longest one I'm looking at
the series right now is the first one
coming in at an hour and 43 minutes so
we're talking about a substantive course
in Renee Gerard's ideas right here so
that's probably enough of my geeking out
about that let me let me let Jonathan
introduce himself and by the way thanks
for coming on I'm very happy to have you
here thanks for having me Greg I mean
the first thing I'll say is uh you know
I think my foray into philosophy you're
one of the the guides the virgils if you
will um I was a sophomore at Columbia
science yeah exactly and maybe through
Purgatory but definitely not all the way
up there
um and I think it was your genealogy of
moral's essay that I think uh really got
me got me very interested and I started
I think I I took a philosophy class
after that and you know I never looked
back so I suppose it's come full circle
so I appreciate all The Works that
you've done as well
um yeah happy to tell share a bit about
myself I was born in Beijing I was
raised between Beijing and Vancouver I
was trained in a competitive math
growing up
um want a Canadian gold medal in the
Pascal competition competed in the
Canadian Olympiad um started coding
quite young and uh got a got a full ride
to Columbia to study computer science I
I dropped out about my my uh freshman
spring I think there's a moment Prestige
to dropping out these days if you get
into an elite computer science program
and I definitely definitely felt prey to
that the company ended up crashing and
burning
um and it was through that failure that
I wanted to as a good engineer as any
good engineer wanted to sort of debug
myself so to speak so so I began looking
for the human equivalent of an API doc
which is what Engineers use to sort of
uh build and communicate the uh
endpoints of their of their Engineering
Systems and for me I I found that in
philosophy and so I ended up finishing
my um CS degree quite early I had
another time in my you know four year
long undergrad from another degree so so
I uh I did a degree in philosophy
um focused mostly on Continental social
philosophy a group of uh theorists that
we can Loosely call recognition
theorists which we can dive into a bit
more today
um and yeah uh you know since graduation
which is about two and a half years
years ago
I started building a fintech company
about my my senior year with Gentlemen
by the name of Joe Lonsdale uh and we're
about you know 40 50 people now and um
yeah cranking cranking at it
um I've uh believe it or not still
managed to find some time for for
contemplation since graduation uh
producing this lecture series was was
one of them a lot of the we can get into
how that was produced but you know most
of the content was digested in my
undergrad days when I had a bit more
time and mostly these days it's just
production and uh and yeah doing a few
writing writing writing here and there
and and probably lecturing this uh this
summer on Innovation actually so keeping
uh keeping myself busy
that's awesome so Renee Gerard right not
exactly as much of a household name as
some other Continental theorists like
you know Martin Heidegger or Jacques
derida or Shield to lose you know people
who are kind of let's say more trendy or
or perennial interest but he's an
interesting guy lurking in the
background
what what Drew you into studying him and
you know devoting I mean he's got a huge
um Corpus yeah like a bookshelf worth of
of stuff and what what made you want to
study him
I suppose um
the reason we get into things and the
reason we stick with things are some
some are often different so I'll you
know tackle those separately I think I
got into for two reasons a primary and a
secondary one the primary reason was as
I described I've just failed at a
company and
um that failure was a failure that I had
you know never faced before which is it
was a very internal failure I.E it
wasn't you know I genuinely wanted to
I don't know lift a certain amount of
weights and I just couldn't do it no
matter how hard I tried but it was very
much a a deeper failure and a uh earlier
failure in some sense in that my desires
themselves were sort of the ones that
were leading me astray like I kind of
knew I didn't want to do it
um but I still felt pulled in doing it
there was a uh
there was some kind of force within me
some desire within me that was sort of
leading me astray and you know Prima
facial that desire was was me and so I
think that's the real sweet spot that
Gerard tries to tries to tackle and
tries to explain with this theory of
metaphysical desire and medic desire and
so I just felt it was deeply relevant um
so that's that's the first reason right
which is
and and I would say this is a more
General point which is uh the flaw I
really enjoy philosophy primarily as a
satiriological tool ceteriology being
the uh you know the salvation of the
soul and I I don't think most people
practice philosophy like this
um these days anymore where it's meant
to fundamentally transform your
character I think philosophy at least an
academy is treated much more like a
career right where yes what one produces
and you know there's obviously many
benefits with that but you know for me
and I think in the classical world uh
philosophy or one of its uh cons one of
its key ends if it's not its primary end
was supposed to invoke a transformation
of character right so so that's what got
me originally into philosophy and the
primary reason I'm still reading uh so
much despite Noah enforcing these so to
speak and and those are the philosophers
that I that I really got into or you
know the Buddhists um Gerard uh and
these group of recognition theories
which we can discuss later on so that's
the first point which is I wanted to
resolve key issues in my life and and
this was the best uh best best thing to
delete me lead me forward and give me an
understanding of what's going wrong
um the second one is probably the you
know memetic influence of of Peter Thiel
right who is someone who's very much
looked up to in the technology
entrepreneur sector
um and you know I I think it's quite
funny when
for almost every author if if you admit
that that you only got into him or her
because of X or Y right because I you
know teal recommended it or or or
Zuckerberg recommended it it's sort of a
critique of their work because you're
kind of saying look I don't know if
there's that much value there but you
know if these values dependent then
maybe it's not so great right right
right right but um but in some sense in
Gerard's Theory it's not a critique of
the work because you are you're either
forced to say well you only like it
because Peter likes it in which case if
that's what Gerard's Theory says right
or or you're forced to say there's you
know there's a real value there anyways
that's just like a humorous side comment
but you know at the end of the day the
reason I stuck with Gerard is um I uh
you know
I found a lot of his uh prescriptions as
well as diagnoses to be the most uh
poignant to our to our time
um not to say I'm not extremely
interested in other thinkers as well but
um but I said to him for that reason you
know
yeah it sounds like what you're getting
out of Gerard is what what a lot of
people call a philosophy is a way of
life which is more typically Associated
you know pure adult was the one who
coins that phrase but there's lots of
other people doing similar things you
know uh Aleister McIntyre's notion of
tradition constituted rationality and
inquiry is really the same sort of thing
and and that was a very
um prevalent mode of philosophy I'd say
all the way up to the 19th century even
people like Descartes are doing
philosophy as a way of life
so typically when people talk about that
they're looking mostly at ancient
philosophy and future ethics like
stoicism you know aristotelianism or
they bring up existentialism and you
know someone like or you know if they're
doing Continental philosophy sometimes
they'll pick up on somebody like Duluth
or Duluth sugar guard right yeah and you
know I kind of feel like how do you live
as a delusion people come up with
all sorts of angles on that but they're
usually most just just you know rattling
around jargon I'm going to be a body
without organs and you're like what the
hell does that mean with with Gerard it
seems like you've got
something that is covering some of the
same ground of virtue ethics and also
looking at you know modernity and and
shifts that are happening so kind of
like along the lines of existentialism
without getting into let's call it just
the cyclical soup of regurgitating you
know jargon and ideas that is
characteristic of a lot of Continental
philosophy right so I guess one of the
questions I would ask was it partly the
milieu at Columbia
um why why Gerard and not more the
philosophies as a way of life that that
get talked about how did how did you end
up you know was there a professor who
steered you in that time right right
right
um so no the answer was uh no to both
questions it was not the Miley of
Colombia or or a professor I am I I
investigated his entire Corpus basically
by myself with the the the accompaniment
of my best friend actually who had read
in high school
um but there was nothing in the
institution so to speak that really
pushed me in that direction if anything
I think my very well intentioned and you
know friends of mine my professors have
uh you know tried to warn me against
your arm because uh because of uh his
unpopularity right basically nudge nudge
wink wink if you want to jaw don't don't
study Gerard
um yeah and so it was very much uh you
know against and not because or or
despite or not because of going to
Colombia now Colombia has a great
Continental Department maybe one of the
best uh you know 1920 Century
Continental departments in the world
um so there was definitely that uh
tangential influence perhaps
um but there's no direct encouragement
in for Gerard and you know that that
raises a very interesting question of
you know why Gerard to your point is uh
is not a household name or even
respected in the academy
um and and this is by the way so right
now I think Gerard is only really taken
seriously in literary criticism
um comparative literature departments
but that even that wasn't wasn't the
case almost about I would say 10 15
years ago and so I think the answer to
this question of why Gerard has been
taken seriously there's there's
generally two sets of answers here right
one set of answers charitable drugs just
you know to claim that he should be
taken seriously but there's reasons he
isn't that's contingent uh or the other
one is just to point into flaws of
Gerard's Theory and so I think both are
probably true I mean on the charitable
side
um Gerard would say that his conversion
towards Christianity was not helpful at
all in this sort of Western sphere in
terms of getting him accepted his his
first book was his career was off to a
great start a desire to see it in the
novel
um which was a uh
psychology you know literary criticism
about some of the great European
novelists
and suddenly when he published his some
consider his says magnum opus uh things
hidden which is a you know explicitly
Christian book you know sort of uh the
whole field went silent so to speak
right and so
um
the other charitable responses would be
that you know he has no respect for
disciplinary boundaries right he jumps
between anthropology psychology
philosophy
um but maybe there's boundaries
shouldn't really be there in the first
place
um and another charitable explanation is
then he's a he's a true system builder
right in an age where you know adorno
negative dialectics is very skeptical of
of systems and wants
um philosophers essentially to be
technicians right investigating these
very manageable sort of chunks of these
questions
um so those are the charitable readings
to draw of you know he's a right person
there's a genuine genuine value in his
theory but just the historical Miley was
not there to appreciate him but but I
also do think that that's not the end of
the story right so
um I think uh for him he for houses for
how systematic his philosophy pertains
to be he himself is not a very
systematic writer
um his arguments sometimes lack rigor
but they lack and rigor they more than
make up for in style I would say
um right and richness and he's a bit
loose in his argumentation he's about
you know Conjuring these figures up to
you and these intuition is up to you
even if they're not perfectly argued
um and you know frankly I have major
disagreements with with each part of of
his words you know I'm not a Christian
he is a Christian right I think he's uh
focused on the medic theory is right and
maybe um as good historical corrective
measure but it's not the full extent of
the story and the saying goes for his
his social theory so uh there's
definitely a lot of gripes I have with
this Theory and I I think I said in the
introductory lecture I could make a
whole whole extra series just on those
disagreements
um so I think for those you know reasons
whether charitable to him or
uncharitable to him
um I think I think he's just not he has
not been um received in the academy and
therefore no one normally guided me so
it was again it was it's really it's
really this serological point of of
wanting to solve problems that I thought
I mean you know and this is going back
quite a ways into the 1990s I remember
encountering him and it wasn't any
Professor who was recommending him
either it was fellow grad students
saying oh there's this really cool thing
happening with this guy we should take a
look at it and so we we had like a
little
um reading group that we would bring
other thinkers in who we weren't getting
in our curriculum you know and so he was
sort of like
um you know people would read just so
sir and and nobody wanted to teach that
or they would read matai you know all of
these kind of
either they were viewed as foundational
but nobody was going to read them or
they were viewed as kind of eccentric
you know recour nobody wanted to really
read him but we we read him as well and
I think those those now those those guys
are a little bit older than Gerard but
right they all kind of figure into that
Motif I was intrigued too with you
saying that you have a lot of
disagreements with Gerard on fundamental
matters and yet you decided to invest
the time and attention and work and even
money we can say we'll talk about that
in a bit in creating this video series
and I have something kind of similar you
know I've got this half hour Hegel
Series yeah I'm taking that right now by
the way I'm going through the cloud
analogy and and then yeah using your
half hour Series yeah you know it's much
lower production but it's it's much
longer than people be like well he must
be a hegelian or else he wouldn't be
doing this and then I'll say no no I'm
I'm not I think hegel's got a ton of
stuff wrong but I think that it's worth
putting in the time to explain it and so
I see a similar Motif in your I mean
pretty massive project that you've
you've put out
um I mean am I on base about that you're
totally on base I mean I I think um
it's really really since graduating from
Colombia that I really gained a uh
gratitude for the philosophy education I
received there because again the
department was I would say heavily
continental and it's unlikely in these
days to find it in the certainly in
America even departments that are
Continental period much less more
Continental than analytic
um and so my training was very much and
you know as Columbia I was famous for in
the sort of great books tradition in
this sort of tradition of being a
charitable interpreter to someone that
that you might disagree with and at the
end of the day I think you just get so
much more out of that I mean just
um I I can I can you know uh that there
was many positions within Gerard that I
wouldn't have taken seriously
um but after trying to interpret him as
charitably as possible being his
defensive lawyer almost to some extent
um that now I've uh you know seen to to
have to have some Merit right and so I
think there's Great Value to be had in
just trying to be the most charitable
defensive lawyer to each of the you know
uh
when you're doing that defensive
lawyering you know are you doing this
sort of
dialogically with yourself where you're
also the prosecutor raising right yeah I
don't think this is good and then you
expect or is this more like what you're
doing with interlocutors friends
colleagues you know they you let them
present the charges and then you try to
defend this guy who you still yeah yeah
you're right right right well I think
maybe the analogy is being drawn a bit
too far here there's actually no back
and forth going on either within me or
or um obviously when I write I take on a
somewhat dialectical approach of raising
my own objections and trying to
reconcile them um but but in terms of
creating the lecture it was really um
maybe it's the first speech of the
defensive lawyer where where there's no
attacks yet right just me just trying to
present as charitable case as possible
and then even then right I I don't agree
with with some of the things that that
um I was interpreting
um but but yeah so so I I this mode of
uh interpreting uh you know previous
masterpieces is how I most naturally
sort of attack philosophy so yeah
now let's talk about the video series
then that's a good segue into it so I
was gonna start out talking about the
production and your decision to do that
but actually let's talk about one of the
format things you have you have two
intermarketers facing each other
um you know it's classic interview or
conversation format they're in this very
Lush
um kind of club-like atmosphere uh
dressed up and what's what was what was
the idea behind that uh the the
interlocutor format specifically yeah
yeah well there's practical and
aesthetic I would say
um aesthetically Gerard has I would say
three maybe four different type of books
he has
um essentially interviews he has
anthologies of his essays he has book
books designers scene in the novel and
he has essentially dialogues and how he
would create these dialogues in his
magnum opus things hidden since the
foundations of the world is a is one of
these dialogues is he would have
conversations with his good friends
um and it wouldn't be once one
transcribes but it would be heavily
edited but that kind of forms the
skeleton of the word yeah and in a
similar manner so me coming so my
interlocutor was a one of my best
friends by the name of David perrell and
he's much more experienced in uh sharing
ideas in the public domain whereas my
training is much more in the academic
philosophy domain so
um what I did in producing these
lectures was
um through my undergrad I had written a
lot of the scripts out already and so I
just sit David down and I I would go
through the lecture and I would see his
reactions where it wasn't making sense
where where I was losing him where he
had interesting things to add I
transcribed all that and then I rewrote
that rewrote the whole thing so I think
if I had just given the the initial
thing that I could I get gave David I
think it would have been just as
theoretically sound but it would have
been a lot less engaging for the for the
public audience that makes sense and so
um so the first reason is it's aesthetic
you know I wanted to sort of somewhat
honor uh the the format that that uh
that Gerard had
um and the second one is really just is
really just practical David was the one
who was always encouraging me
encouraging me to do this he has a great
uh business essentially teaching people
to publish ideas online and
um he's my great great friend so so I
really wanted to do that and however
because of the complexity and the
enormity of the ideas that we had to
cover in a short span of time 10 hours
doesn't seem short but for the ground
recovered I think I think it was
actually quite quite efficient
um I knew that I couldn't just give off
the cuff lecturing I had to have
everything written down and and this has
to do with the aesthetic by the way I
I'm I'm someone who's very much all or
none in almost everything I do be it
dating or relationships or writing or
producing video lectures where I either
want to make something that's excellent
um or I don't want to make anything at
all and which explains perhaps the sort
of classical Aesthetics for being
charitable there but as well as the you
know Precision with language that I had
to have so if you actually zoomed out
from the frame that Central frame when
you look at me and David there was a
prop there was a projector right behind
David so every word that I said was
one-to-one written written out before
now I think that it unfortunately had
led to a very robotic delivery and
including my sort of back and forth
where date with David was extremely
robotic and cringe-worthy in retrospect
so going forward I don't think I'm going
to do that format anymore I think I'm
either gonna yeah go ahead I don't I
don't get that impression and I'm
wondering so I mean it's pretty common
with people who are
um lecturers performers everything in
between to be hyper-critical
of their own work in part because they
they know what went into it so like I'm
I'm hyper aware every time that I say
you know which is like my verbal tick of
having done it once again but it doesn't
seem like anybody else is bothered by it
and I'm wrong right right if maybe that
isn't the case for your own evaluation
of your video series I would love for
that to be the case but I think there's
people in the comments section who have
echoed a similar sort of concern as well
so but you know it's a it's a war zone
down there right so so there's other
people saying everything anyways long
story short I think in the future I'm
either going to do interviews like we're
doing now if I want to do interviews or
I'm just going to lecture directly into
the camera and this summer um for
example I think I'm going to be
um just giving an in-person lecture
that's going to be filmed so so are you
going to stick with content under Gerard
or are you going to Branch out no other
areas no I don't think so I mean I think
there's there's another lecture series
with Gerard
um I think something like Advanced
topics in the medic Theory and that that
goes beyond Gerard and Gerard's perhaps
interface with the Canon or some
unresolved problems in Gerard yeah I
think it could be very interesting but
my philosophical interests I think span
uh I think further further Beyond uh
further Beyond Gerard
so this is a great time to switch to
that topic of you know bringing up the
Rec uh recognitive view of human nature
and some of the people that you
mentioned are you know uh Adam Smith uh
Jean-Jacques Rousseau
um Hegel uh then some some newer people
Axel hanath uh new Hauser and Gerard you
also mentioned David Hume in the videos
as somebody who's you know I think
you're right about that yeah
um and you know he and Smith are are
pretty close together
so
um
is there a tradition you would say of
we could whatever we're going to call it
you know philosophy of recognition
recognitive philosophy I mean it seems
like this does play an important role
this thematic but I mean does it go all
the way back to Aristotle and Plato
right or how do you see this uh how do I
mean I guess I'm asking how do you look
at your own
um commitments and yeah yeah I think
that's super interesting and I think
this is a great segue because I'm
eventually going to argue that we should
Place Gerard in this tradition and this
is also the sort of where my
philosophical interests are at the
moment I think I think of other
interests but
um and you know the other thing I'll
caveat is you know none of this is is
original maybe then other than putting
Gerard in this tradition I was very
fortunate to study with two of the
philosophers that you mentioned Axel
hanath and Professor uh for newhauser uh
who are who are sort of the world
experts in in cognitive theory and but
maybe let me set back a little bit to
describe the personal issue I think I
was facing okay startup because I think
this will also lead in there I think
what I realized when I was uh you know
failing to build the startup was that
and I think this is a common concern
here many many people uh vocalize that
they care a bit too much about what
other people think right that there's a
that they are being swayed one way or
the other by uh by the opinions of the
group or specific individuals around
rather than their own sort of genuine
desire and so and I think that's a
really interesting segue into
recognition Theory because um I think
that's one of the key concerns that it
attempts to address
um but if it's okay if it's okay with
you maybe maybe do a little intellectual
history is actually helpful in framing
what really captured me about
recognition Theory and why I think um
it's so interesting to me
um a lot of this is going to be borrowed
from my professor Axel Hahn's book I
think struggle for recognition I think
that was his first major work so people
who are interested
um uh could go there and he also has a
book coming out just called recognition
which gives an overview of these three
Traditions Scottish moral philosophy
um uh the French German Traditions
respectively so
I would locate to answer your question
positively
um this tradition all the way going back
to Plato with his tripartite division of
the Soul right and what's interesting
about that is that each part of the Soul
not only has its own means but it has
its own ends right so the repetitive
part you know maybe that's our instincts
it has its own end which is you know
pleasure sex shelter right whatever we
share with animals and then you have the
rational part and I think uh people who
first learned this in modernity are
surprised to learn that the rational
part has an end and that's contemplative
Joy right
um and and then there's the the last
part
um and that's Spirit right and and that
is seeking all these social goods like
Glory belonging and it wants to avoid
like disrespect
and
I think you can trace this tradition
um all the way you know to Aristotle and
maybe some of the early theologians
um like Augustine that sees
participation in the community this is
the spirited part of the Soul not only
as generative of constitu of uh of
instrumental Goods for the self but as
either being sorry but as both being
part of oneself I.E it's not that easy
to separate the eye from the we right
using hegelian terminology right um and
and also the good
itself is the participation in the
social world so it's not that we
participate in the social world to have
certain Goods but as we participate in
the social world as of the social goods
right and uh you know my professor
professor hanov uh identified the break
from this tradition and you know if
there's many breaks to be identified
with this thinker in Machiavelli
Machiavelli
saw humans or at least a political actor
that he was advising as the as an
egoistic sort of person who's concerned
primarily or perhaps uh you know a
majority for one's own uh ends of
appetite right survival right and if
Machiavelli is the first to introduce
this idea of human conception uh
Professor Hana if I think I uh treats
Hobbes the Leviathan as the thing that
institutionalizes this conception of
human nature into the as the basis of
social theory or political philosophy
yeah um because even though right glory
is one of the reasons people fight in
the state of War of all against all
um the state is set up not really to
address the glory and recognition piece
it's mostly set up so that people stop
killing each other right and so that's
the basis of a state
and you know to this tradition of
thinkers I think I would have to add
Smith
now you may be surprised because I
included Smith originally in this realm
of recognition theorists but I think
it's safe to say that Smith saw a large
part of the social worlds and probably
economics primarily as being governed by
these egoistic impulses right yeah it's
not from the benevolence of the butcher
that we expect our daily meal but a
concern for his own self-interest
and so and even if this line of thinking
that and I I guess what what this modern
uh twist so to speak uh is doing is that
it's ignoring the spirited part of
ourselves
and then removing the ends of reason and
so what what we become is we become
utility maximizing machines
we use the means of reason to advance
the ends of appetite right so it's a
very reduced picture of human nature and
you know even if this is not the most
sophisticated understanding of of humans
in the Academy I think it is very much
in in the real world right and be it in
Silicon Valley where you often hear you
know we're just chemicals squirting
other happy chemicals or sad chemicals
depending on the day or you know how
high uh priority GDP has become right
and GDP essentially is the
quantification the calculation the
irrationalization of appetite right I
mean it's one of those things that's
quite funny because yeah if it's let's
say it's false right and I think there's
good reasons to think that that sort of
let's call it pseudohumian because Hume
you know has that nice line reason can
only be the slave of the passions but he
doesn't really believe that you look at
the rest of the treaties and clearly
reason has a major role to play
um but when enough people believe that
and behave according to that and you
mentioned Silicon Valley is a great
example of that or you know a
Contemporary American politics where
things become much more zero-some and
it's extended into this vast culture war
and all of this monkeying around with
the very mechanics of politics so like
gerrymandering and you know all these
these laws to restrict voting
um if enough people behave that way if
you have a critical mass of
people who believe themselves to be
egoists then you're kind of stuck with
it aren't you right it becomes very
difficult to bring in anything that
won't get subverted and this is a
hobbsian problematic I mean Hobbes one
of the reasons why he doesn't want
anybody who's not licensed to be
teaching moral theory and he wants the
Plato and Aristotle and Cicero books to
be to be banned is because people can
use that stuff just to further their own
ads you know it's sort of like window
dressing right right what they want to
do you know yeah that's totally right
and so maybe there's building off of
what you said the question is what's so
wrong about this reduced view of human
nature even if it is wrong right let's
let's say if it's wrong what are we
missing
um I don't think what's at stake is
whether we are essentially Cooperative
or competitive creatures like and that's
why I introduced Smith right because
from this egoistic position we get a
Cooperative social ontology in in Smith
of course we get a competitive one in
Machiavellian hops what I think is at
stake is is we two things first we
ignore
um a species maybe even the most
important species of human good right to
treat the to treat the interaction with
others as the good and not only
instrumentally as something that
provides us real Goods
um but also on the opposite side
I think we also ignore the extent of
human depravity right take this as an
example Why did um why did Achilles drag
Hector's body after he had already died
if if we were really just rational
utility creatures well you know Achilles
self-preservation is no longer at stake
now that Hector has died why did he feel
this additional impulse to sort of Shame
him right and that that I think is much
more easily explained with Spirit right
why you would sort of mutilate an
already already dead body so I think
ignoring the spirited part of ourselves
the social part of ourselves right Zoom
politicon
um what we miss is is tremendous on one
hand we are sort of blind or we're not
able to sort of participate in perhaps
the most important species of human good
which is you know interactions with the
community and on the other hand we sort
of underestimate the capacity for human
evil so so it's really a big deal but I
think we're we're over with this and why
I think
um this line of thinkers as well as
Gerard was fascinating to me
is because if you treat rationality as
many people do today to mean
utility maximizing for appetite then
Gerard and these line of thinkers are
able to
rationalize the irrational part of
ourselves
they're able Gerard is able to tease out
a logic for the illogical part of
ourselves
and and so right which is to say that
the spirited part of ourselves this
social aspect of ourselves it has its
own logic it's not completely random and
that can be studied and resolved and
this actually goes back not only to sort
of Designing good communities or
interactions with the world but how to
structure one's own life right because
in my example I I had no control over
the spirit part of myself because I
didn't even know that that was something
I needed to control and this goes back
in fact to my original claim of many
people these days think
I ought to stop caring what other people
think
right but but I think if you take these
recognition theorists seriously
that's something impossible like that's
like saying I ought not to breathe and
because constitutions do these
recognition thinkers is that they all
think that recognition is a species of
human good that um you know it's not
that we can't live you know physically
on them but that we will feel inevitably
uh pulled towards that and when you
really look at people who who say that
who declare and advertise it I don't
want to care I don't care what other
people think I think many of the times
what they're saying is I want people to
think of me as someone who doesn't care
about what what I what they think of me
and so
um yeah maybe I'll pause there uh to to
following up on that I think that
there's quite a few people who labor
under anxiety or fear right of being
labeled as somebody who cares what other
people think right right right and it's
it's kind of similar to those who are
saying oh I'm not going to be ruled by
fear I won't wear a mask you know during
this pandemic and you're like you're
totally ruled by fear you're you're
afraid of being of looking like uh you
know a cupcake or right right cream puff
as we say right so I think there's that
aspect and then I think you're right
that not recognizing what we can call
the fumotic domain that it has a logic
and a structure and goods inherent to it
um we we really any risk cutting
important stuff out of our life you know
um we should care about what what other
people think and introducing evil into
our life that that right we aren't aware
of right or and or cooperating with
other people's evil you could say yeah
um but you know Aristotle when he's
talking about
um the life pursuing on or he's like
well
you don't care about what everybody
makes of you if you do there's something
wrong with you and this is what I think
you know whenever I talk about it in
class I talk about celebrities who seem
to be very clearly driven by this need
to have everybody love them right
everybody say good things about them
indiscriminately and they get very upset
when somebody you know contravenes those
desires right right you know really we
should care I don't want to say we
should only care about like what the
super intelligent and the greatly
virtuous people think of us I think we
should care what our families think of
us right yeah right right right all
right our close friends you know and I
think that's exactly the question that
uh is so interesting uh to me right
having suffered my my own sort of
struggles early on which is once you
start taking these recognition theories
seriously you don't ask how can I stop
caring what other people think you ask
what is the right relationship of caring
what other people think right yeah what
what should I care about when they say
it what state uh from which they say it
is legitimate who write should I care
about and and what what about me do I
need external validation on
um and and I I and maybe to flush this
out a little bit more
um I would I would Define recognition as
a confirmation from another
Consciousness that one indeed holds a
certain normative quality
okay so so
and and the different strands and of
course the different authors and the
different schools so to speak of
recognition Theory all have uh different
answers to what the right social
relationship is and how important
recognition really is right for example
there's some interpretations of 50 who
thinks that without recognition
Consciousness itself in some sense is is
impossible and there's some
interpretation right interpreters of
Rousseau right who thinks that
um
that reason itself is dependent on uh at
least the channels of animal prop right
the recognition that that that at least
reason and Amor prop go through the very
similar channels
um and of course there's people like
Smith who treat you know in this case
sympathy species of recognition as as as
one important good amongst a different
spectrum of other Goods right so so
yeah I I hope it's clear to our to our
audience why this is such an interesting
and pertinent and relevant question to
living our everyday lives I I mean I
think it is something that everybody can
relate to and if you can't relate to it
that I mean it'd be sort of like the
Aristotle observation the person who can
live alone is either an animal or a God
they're not a human being you know
um and I was thinking you know Hegel
somebody we've we've brought up a little
bit so you know with him it's on air
cannon and it's it plays a massively
important role within the phenomenology
uh less so I would say yeah the Logics
but it's also there in the philosophy of
right as absolutely Central as well and
you know there has been some attention
to this I'd say that that Brandon's
recent work uh yep really picks up on
this and there are some people who work
with hegelian ethics
um and and what I you know I think Hegel
the system doesn't work you know you
know clearly history didn't end in 1807
or you know even in the 18 uh 20s or 30s
or anything like that but this concept
that part of what's driving not just the
historical process but even the drive
for
academic knowledge is recognition
um I think that's a very fruitful idea
but we should we should we should flesh
this out before we run out of time
because I I know where we've been
talking about this a while in terms of
specifically gerardian ideas so you know
I would guess and I it's not like I've
done some scientific survey on this but
if there's one idea that's particularly
most strongly associated with Gerard
it's memetic desire so why don't you run
us through what that is and then you
mentioned metaphysical desire how do
these differ
um and why why is my medic desire so
important as a concept
yeah that's very interesting and I think
um
you know for different thinkers you have
to understand what their first
philosophy is right first philosophy
being what their starting point is and
and for Gerard for psychology is first
philosophy um I would say perhaps not
unlike someone like Nietzsche and so it
might desire is so Central to Gerard's
Theory uh because
um his entire social theory and even
theology takes on an argument of a
psychological form
um but in terms of this question to
tackle it directly I actually don't like
using the the phrase memetic desire for
strong reasons that that I won't get
into but I much prefer as thinking
humans as having two species of Desire
one being metaphysical and one of course
being physical desire and this is a very
minority interpretation so you know okay
on my website I give a defense of why
why I choose to interpreter this way but
to give you the view directly
um metaphysical desire is a concern for
being for identity whereas physical
desires concern turn for utility or for
for use or for doing right and you know
a few examples are I can desire to you
know have sex with a certain person for
for experience right physical desires
experience metaphysical desires being
um and that would be the in the moment
sort of Pleasures or or the the sense of
intimacy or I could have sex with
someone because of who having sex with
someone says about me right and this is
a real psychology this is a psychology
of the Don Juan or the croquette right
the sexual the sexual uh Conquistador
and
this cuts across one may say many human
domains right one can do philosophy
because one wants to be the next Hegel
or one wants to get tenure at a fancy
University one can also do philosophy
because they're in pain and they want to
find something to sort of uh save their
soul so to speak
um of course jobs it's very easy to see
this in jobs as well right
um most investment bankers at least that
I know of are forced to be very prideful
because there's no real physical desire
right the job itself is not a very
enjoyable experience of doing
spreadsheets until three three a.m so
you kind of um you're kind of forced to
jockey to to new beneficials are and so
once you start seeing human desires it's
always constituted by these two threads
who are in some sense competing for Real
Estate I think there's a lot of
interesting uh phenomenon that that pop
up and you know one example that I'll
give you is
um you know I did both Cs and philosophy
and my undergrad and the philosophy kids
were much more interesting and much less
prideful and I would say just much more
sober to talk to
um and you know why is that uh and
I I would say it's because uh computer
science has become so prestigious these
days in philosophy you know waning in
Prestige I would say yeah that there's a
lot of ulterior reasons why when we want
to do you know computer science be it
job opportunities or good old Prestige
uh words for philosophy you know it's
really useless
um at least at least in most ways that
people think of use and so really people
who are just interested in the subject
themselves uh um you know sort of uh
approach that and so in what sense is
metaphysical desire mimetic
um I think it's mimetic in the sense
that when we desire to be Gerard thinks
that we're all very let me pause for one
sec the being that Gerard thinks we are
after is it can be interpreted
colloquially as a existing and great
measure and so that's to have a certain
amount of power right you can think of
Nietzsche's Will To Power which is about
exerting oneself and manifesting one's
own self-conception right and as we all
know Nietzsche's Will To Power in his
third s in the genealogy can manifest in
seemingly powerless ways in each's case
the the aesthetic right the aesthetic is
still exerting his power and and that's
similar to Gerard Gerard thinks that
um his desire to be metaphysical desire
is deeply malleable and depending on
which models we are trying to imitate
they can take on an extremely different
uh uh they can take out many forms
um this being is also one for
recognition right for attention and for
a lane for a name to last so I really
interpreted this being as uh you know
desire for core you know metaphysical
Concepts a desire for power causality a
desire for recognition reality right
social reality uh ontology and um it
does desire to be Eternal right
temporality and so it's this grandiose
sense of being that Gerard thinks we're
all after and that we're all secretly
lacking through our psychology is deeply
pessimistic one and Gerard thinks that
then the question is how do we get this
being and Gerard because it's so Elusive
and so abstract right and Gerard thinks
that we look to models whom we wrongly
so attribute this degree of being and
try to imitate them their normative
values their habits their tastes get
taken on by us
um as if if we obtain them we would we
would achieve the greater greater degree
of being and you know and I think one
thing that this explains is you know why
so many of the things that we lust for
getting to a good school dating a
specific partner or making a lot of
money often a relationship with them is
as like a mirage I.E only appealing when
we haven't arrived at the place right
and so Gerard's very uh model of desire
as a chasing a wrong a wrong chasing of
a certain desire that can never be
satisfied right of this grandiose being
uh sort of bakes that in so it's a very
pessimistic form of um and so that's why
it's memetic right that's why it's
social it's because depending on who who
you conceive to have this greater degree
of being it could be a celebrity it
could be a slightly more advantageous
co-worker right it could be a previous
lover
um you you imitate different things
based on your social environment yeah so
two things come to mind as you're saying
that one is just sort of a an
interesting example you think about how
expensive weddings have become and the
massive pageantry associated with them
and the entire Industries around
catering to it and you know it's easy to
spend I mean it's not easy unless you
don't have if you don't have the money
but it's easy to spend 50 Grand on a
typical American Wedding and I think
that's what the average is now which
just strikes me as somebody who's gone
through being married and been at other
people's weddings as an incredible
extravagance and and foolishness because
you're never getting I mean you can have
your pictures you can have your slice of
wedding cake that you'll eat a year
later you can go on your honeymoon and
stuff like that but you're really never
getting any of that stuff back there is
a certain importance to it you know you
invite people to it because that's a
form of recognition it's like well you
get to be part of this but the you know
for most people getting married I think
the day goes by in such a quick blur
with so many different stress points
that it's it's not it's not a great
investment you know all that money right
off doing I mean there are things that
could be good Investments go to marriage
counseling before you even married and
like you know figure your stuff out so
you don't have big fights
um so it's kind of an interesting
example and I think we could multiply
them in terms of all sorts of other
things that people do invest their time
and money and attention into which means
taking away from other stuff right
because we're always prioritizing but
the other thing I was going to say is so
you know from a gerardian perspective
once we're like maybe you could say even
reasonably intelligent children we can
start to have some inkling that there's
there's some freedom on our part we can
choose different models as you said
right we can recognize that the models
that we're pursuing are probably not
going to pay off the way that we want
even if we do happen to be lucky enough
to get to the the uh the Finish Line
with them but you know as children it
seems to me that
um one of the one of the problems that
we have is that we all have a childhood
in which we
I won't say we had models necessarily
forced upon us although that is the case
for some kids but we were presented with
some and then they turned out to be the
wrong models because there is no right
one yeah totally and so you know we're
all screwed up in different ways you
know like some some people are like you
and I go getters you could say right we
want to Excel and do things and there's
other people who are like nah that's not
for me I just want to have a nice quiet
life but that's probably not going to
from a gerardian perspective it's not
gonna pay off any better necessarily you
know so we all get we all inherit some
messed up models and then we have to
like see our way to
rationally selecting marginally better
ones right it's not as if we can ever
have the best model
yeah I mean there's so much there
um but the perhaps the one thing I'll
say is that Gerard um and he he says
this very explicitly himself he's not in
the business of getting giving
prescriptions you know perhaps not
unlike marks right who's not in the
business of making uh cookbooks for the
recipe shops of the future sorry recipes
with the cook shops of the future
um so whatever prescriptions one derives
out of Gerard is really going to have to
be you know you sort of yanking it out
of him
um
I think there are two I think clear
strategies in terms of you know living
philosophy uh for life so to speak to
continue this train of thought of after
you if you accept this this realm of
thinking yeah one is that metaphysical
desire for Gerard is always problematic
because it's always an uh imminent
failure like a mirage it always fails to
deliver on what it provides you but that
doesn't mean that it has no use in
society right and I think um again
drawing to this recognition Theory idea
of uh Rousseau's animal prop right this
desire for self-esteem let's say very
colloquially I believe in the second
discourse uh Rousseau said something
like you know to this drive we owe our
you know criminals and our rapists and
all the other evil people but we also
owe our great uh philosophers and
intellects and musicians and and when
you look at people who are hyper uh
successful they are driven by this right
it's kind of like one-upping each other
even some of the great Renaissance
artists were you know Donatello built
that big dome I gotta build a better
dome right like and so
there's a
it's interesting George thinks that we
are in do we are chased by metaphysical
desire
insofar as you know two things and so
far as we are prideful that is to say in
so far the power causality temporality
and the ontology the realness the
recognition that we want is strong
that's what pride is for Gerard and
insofar as our lack is weak I.E the
Delta of what we want our being to be is
the Delta is the force behind
metaphysical desire
so there's really two strategies I would
say one strategy is to align your
metaphysical with your physical desires
right and you know to put it very simply
you can think of your physical desires
as your authentic desires things you you
enjoy uh you know not because of what
they say about you or despite what they
say about you right
um and metaphysical Czar being the uh
how society and social expectations gets
added upon you
and so one strategy is to try to align
metaphysical and physical desire and try
to use that however deceitful Boost from
metaphysical desire to physical to
further your physical ends for example
you know doing philosophy instead of Cs
and being surrounded by philosophy
professors who sort of hold you know
understanding great books to high
Prestige uh instead of being surrounded
by you know CS professors right
um and the other strategy
is to reduce one's Pride or fulfills
one's lack and and there are ways to do
this one one way is to retreat from
society right to be very distant from
the models that really draw you draw you
close and you know maybe stoic or
Buddhist Meditation is another way in
meditating on your on your death uh
could also help you reduce your pride
but I would say that those are the two
strategies that that sort of come to
mind so to speak
um and so I think Gerard wants to say
um we can't always choose our models
um and I think your intuition is right
that early on I think we get
some models in part their normative
values on us that is very very difficult
if not impossible for us to shake
and even in adulthood there are
social environments that are sober in
which case reason can be used in Blossom
and in in Social environments where
pride is so inflamed that we're just
memetic creatures being being chased off
that part the spirit of part of cells
and for example this ties everything
nightly namely together one of Gerard's
uh one line sort of critiques of Hobbes
is
um
the social contract is most unavailable
when it is most needed at the height of
War of all against all and what he means
to say here now of course Hobbes
intended the social contract to be a
thought experiment right not as a thing
that sort of actually historically
happens but I think Gerard's critique is
you know it's precisely when people are
at each other's throats when you've
killed my mom and I killed your daughter
that that I can't just sit down with you
and say hey let's let's build a
government because we don't we got to
look for our future self-interest
self-interest appetite is no longer what
I'm concerned about at that moment right
I'm concerned about spirit
and so there are different social
there's different periods in life where
one has more freedom right very close
very trivially very simplistically maybe
in childhood we have less Freedom
growing up perhaps some people have more
but there are within uh within that
there's also certain environments where
we have less and more freedom to choose
our models
you know bringing up pride is a central
Motif and thinking about Gerard as a a
strange kind of Christian uh theorist
right he's not he's not you would say
like imposing Orthodoxy from above or
something like that he thinks that
Christianity provides us with like a way
of terminological lens yeah exactly so
you know traditionally you know pride
has been understood as like the most
problematic of the vices or sins and
then oftentimes it's like paired with
concupiscence or whatever we want to
call it
um mostly bodily desire but it can
easily concupiscence can easily easily
extend into avarice or greed or stuff
like that
um and these are sort of like the double
whammy that we have to worry about you
know according to a lot of Christian
thinkers do you think that Gerard is not
giving enough attention he's giving so
much attention to Pride and it's its
place through recognition and stuff like
that and not enough to concupise yeah
right and concupiscence if I understand
you correctly
um is sort of uh lust right or or yeah
it includes all those but also greed uh
right that's right that's right that's
such a good point I would say in fact
once you draw the metaphysical and
physical desire and you say metaphysical
desire bad even if you agree with that
the immediate reaction another way to
frame your question is wait but physical
desire isn't always good yeah right we
could desire uh pedophilia that that
presumably is a physical desire right
because you don't want to be pedophiles
or we could desire you know doing drugs
right and that could be done to uh
I was gonna say even just indifference
to the plight of others greed can
sometimes be something that is more
about you know vanity showing off but
sometimes it's just hey I got mine screw
you you know I don't care about what
happens
and I think Gerard uh is I think guilty
of of this of not
circumscribing the set of physical
desires that are also problematic in
fact the line I'm thinking about in his
magnum opus is being sane is about
excuse me being sane is about having
objects and being busy with them
being crazy is about being obsessed with
models physical metaphysical desires so
Gerard in that world basically says look
all these social metaphysical desires
are are problematic but these physical
desires are not problematic and in fact
I'll give another example okay
um where this this isn't in one of his
uh not often read books he compares the
Romans who sort of induce puke to eat
more with what he can uh I think a
Seinfeld episode where a woman goes to
puke after eating spaghetti and he said
that compared to the the Modern Woman
the Romans were and this is meant to be
a at least a relative praise he called
them innocent sensuous
and what he's getting at there is that
the woman in modernity is puking for
other people to watch her waistline or
at least so draw claims and so that's a
social concern right whereas the Romans
they just they just enjoyed eating right
so much that they needed to empty out
yeah yeah yeah so you can see the Romans
as these you know childlike almost
innocent right which is so funny to
think of gluttony as innocent but you
know how like gluttonous people right
and you know in fact yeah you go I mean
I was going to say an ancient Christian
thought on this lost and gluttony
they're not great right but they're the
most minor of the deadly sins or Capital
devices it's as you get into the
spiritual stuff with pride and vain
Glory at the top and then and then you
got these others in the middle like you
know while greed coming soon after lust
and then you've got wrath
um which is always you know other
directed right and then you've got this
weird mix that at first it's two
different vices Acadia and sadness and
then they get together into sloth and
then we have Envy coming in as well you
know and those are the ones that I mean
it's interesting too because you think
about contemporary Christians and how
obsess so many of them are with sexual
morality and so uninterested in thinking
about economics or greed or anger and
them being in the grip of it or
um you know the pride that that's
motivating things or or Envy itself
well that's precisely right and I think
um I think Dante at least in purgatory
the splitting is the seven levels were
the seven deadly sins the first three
are liking the wrong thing and that's
Pride wrath and envy I think and then
you have uh not liking anything which is
sloth and then you have liking the right
things but in wrong proportion and
that's avarice lust and gluttony yeah
right and so in that view
um I think Gerard is right to elevate
the Roman over the modern bulimic
because the Roman is is liking the right
thing in the wrong proportion whereas
the modern bulimic is liking the wrong
thing vanity right and and so and so uh
perhaps I I think that that is to say
this concern that that Gerard is uh not
giving enough
not making avarice and those bodily sort
of sins uh uh uh concerning is perhaps
somewhat canonical
okay well you know that leads to another
question that I wanted to bring up with
you so you know Gerard is writing
largely you know in the
uh late 20th century right uh along with
all these other Continental theorists
and you know
um things have really changed for us in
very rapid ways with the proliferation
of the internet mobile technology and
all this Tech that is now almost
inextricable from our lives and from our
habits I mean not to look at your phone
every 20 minutes takes a deliberate
effort right uh not least because
they've created all these things to make
us do that to desire that so do you
think that his
his um
concepts are maybe more applicable in
this intranet yeah right right
environment or less so or like half and
half right
that's great well the first thing I'll
say and I I touch upon this already is
that for Gerard uh psychology is first
philosophy and yeah the the benefit of
designing your philosophical system in
that way is that as long as human nature
doesn't change
um you you can it's always somewhat
applicable
um yeah but but it just manifests in
different different portions right and
so I would say Gerard has his first
philosophy is psychology and then it's
the social logic and only then is it
actually social commentary so it's not
like he was just commenting on the 20th
century Cold War for example
um but but he's trying to give you a a
picture of human nature and the logic of
social events that not only does it
cover the 20th century in the current
century but he claims that it also
covers all the way back not only just in
the Christian times Greek times but all
the way from uh sort of our Evolution
from ape so that's how comprehensive
thinks that that that he is scoped out
and and so that's the first cut right
yeah I'll say two more Cuts I'll say two
more cuts
um to answer your question affirmative
an affirmative way I definitely do think
that there is a something you know Cold
War about Gerard right this sort of
perennial concern for Apocalypse
um and this antagonistic picture of
nation states as these dueling twins
which you know unfortunately is becoming
more and more likely now I I think is
perhaps
those like intuitions that that permeate
his work rather than anything
specifically you may point out I think
perhaps is if I'm outdated slightly
anachronistic
um but the last thing I'll say is um or
actually two more things is that you
know Gerard's last work was uh 2008 2010
battling to the end so he's still quite
relevant and he didn't he passed away in
2015 and was you know someone producing
up until then yeah
I mean I wonder if some of these things
aren't more relevant yeah right age
especially for people who grew up with
the internet like you know I'm so I'm a
generation x i
um had my childhood before the internet
existed but you know the adults were all
saying that our brains were going to be
rotted from
um cable television and pick whatever
else you want right so there's this
perennial concern that you see any
literature going all the way back every
generation thinks that the the young
kids are a hot mess and not going to
mount to anything
um but I think there have been some
significant changes in how we relate to
each other and maybe there's greater
dangers you know
um you think take bullying for example
right I mean it used to be you could at
least go home and if you're being
bullied uh I don't know they might throw
eggs at your house or something like
that but yeah at least you had a safe
spot but now if you go home and you get
on your computer and you're one of the
kids who's being singled out
irrationally I mean all the bullying
that we do is is there's a logic to it
but it's always driven by weird crap you
know
um now it's more prevalent and perhaps
this worrying about what other people
think it's it's harder to extricate
yourself from it when you're constantly
being encouraged to like you know pick
up your phone and see who likes your
stuff in social media you know so I mean
what do you do you think that Gerard
would be more relevant because of that
or
yeah yeah I think um this Gerard has
been so in addition to his social theory
and his uh psychology if that's not
enough for one uh one career he also has
a very ambitious uh philosophy of
History where his sort of eschatology is
his sort of final part and so he paints
a
um
story this is the sort of broad stroke
is that the proximity of people have
been closing down and he would say that
the closing down started all the way
since uh the crucifixion actually for
reasons we won't get into because
that'll take too long but yeah what he
means is really two types of distances
closing down one type of distance is
social distance
and that is the uh proliferation of the
ideal of equality so a billionaire and a
worker today may consider each other as
more equal
at least an ideal than say then say Lord
and serf who might just be completely
different creatures right even if the
material inequality has not reduced or
even increased
the other proximity for Gerard that has
decreased is
let's call it spatial temporal proximity
right yeah and this has to do with
travel but also communication and keep
in mind communication has not only been
getting better in the last you know 20
years in in in the internet but you know
the printing press and all those
different Innovations and you know
whereas a peasant in let's say rural
China uh 300 years ago wouldn't have
known anything about uh the habits of
people who've lived Beyond a few mile
radius now sort of you know I can see
what the top guys in Dubai are doing and
what the sort of Instagram influencers
in in in Malibu are doing and Gerard and
this is what makes him an apocalyptic
thinker thinks that both advances of
decreased proximity but especially the
decrease in Social proximity is a
terribly good thing he thinks that it's
the core Christian message for that
equality expands in this way and he
believes that true love can only come
from this equal State however for Gerard
this state of collapsing proximity is
also an apocalyptic State because our
memetic desires so much more readily
travel amongst people right because both
forms of proximity social distance
social distance right if you're a surf
and I'm a lord whatever I do you think
well you know that's because he's Lord
right of course I'm less inclined to
imitate your desires and also spatial
temporal proximity just blocks off the
desire of being transferred now the
reason that Gerard is so worried about
you know our desires uh
um circulating faster is because if we
have similar desires we're going to
compete over a similar set of objects
and that's going to create conflict
right and so
um for Gerard we live in an apocalyptic
moment and we are headed towards an
apocalyptic Direction
um of which the internet and phones is
but mere one step of this long
trajectory he is painting so I would say
his his theory is as relevant as it uh
has ever been
well you know one of the things that we
should touch on before we
um finish up is so he is a Christian
thinker and I mentioned he's not like
what we could call a stick in the mud
Orthodox you know I'm going to
evangelize you Christian thinker and so
what and you mentioned you know
Christianity provides a heuristic lens
what does that actually mean
um how does that work within his works
and you know as somebody who's not a
Christian
um maybe you can say a bit to some of
the people who might be like well I'm
not either and I don't know if I want to
read this guy if he's going to be
preaching at me right so I I guess what
I'm saying is like make a case for why
being a Christian makes him a better
thinker but you don't have to be a
Christian to appreciate him yeah that's
a very interesting question well the
first thing I suppose I have to say is
that you know Christianity is not
um
it's not the starting point of his work
it's the conclusion of his work right
and perhaps that's what you're getting
at by not being stick in the mud right
it's not that you know the first Clan
the first Axiom is you know God is right
and the Bible is right and the second
Axiom is do what the Bible says and
search very much has to build up a
anthropological argument for
Christianity what he calls uh the
anthropology of the cross
and he's giving us what He conceives to
be a scientific argument and his
self-conception to the social sciences
is similar to what Darwin did for the
biological uh Sciences which and of
course whether he's successful right you
know that's another discussion but that
was his self self-conception
um but perhaps for the non for the
non-Christian the first thing I'll say
is there's a lot of things that I don't
touch upon theology in his work if
you're interested
but even his theological claims I would
say again are
very humanistic
in fact I think this point that I'm
trying to make can be framed as a
critique and I tried I did try to frame
it as a critique of drugs theology is
that he's almost giving us an atheistic
Christianity
where sort of God really that isn't that
much in the picture
where
for example
um The Miracles are not brought up as
proof at all for for Christ's Divinity
and even the resurrection Gerard says
well that can't be it because pagan gods
get resurrected all the time and in fact
it's the distancing of the three days in
between for Gerard that that he sees as
uh more of an indication because it
shows that this sort of mythical
resurrection and and violence uh has
been distanced from each other
um yeah so I suppose that that's like uh
the best sort of five minute you know
ten minute defense that I can give is
that yeah Gerard really is giving or
attempting to give an anthropological
argument for why Christianity is unique
and revelatory and that anthropological
argument goes something like this you
know in in times of turmoil human
societies have had to kill an innocent
victim and he called this process a
scapegoat mechanism to really establish
peace and I think the intuition here is
one that you know maybe we can entertain
already which is you know if we're not
rational creatures if we're not
repetitive creatures and we're spirited
creatures and we're suffering spirited
malaise in times of turmoil I think
French Revolution
um then we need an equally spiritual
symbolic cathartic release right killing
Marion Antoinette might not resolve
might not give us the food we need but
it's a it's a sign of Revenge and
retribution right yeah and so
Gerard basically sees human history as
society's declining into chaos and some
societies fortunate enough converge upon
an innocent victim and kill them
essentially out of catharsis and out of
that catharsis came peace and out of
that peace Gerard thinks flowed the
essentially all the other religions
that's non-Christian so whether it's the
Greek gods or the or the pagan gods and
Gerard essentially is arguing that
something radically different is
happening Christianity and and the first
intuition is well no that's the exact
same thing that has happened in
Christianity a mob descends on Jerusalem
it's angry it kills Jesus how is that
not an attack of Christianity of its
anthropological Origins and Gerard's
answer is going to be that Christianity
is the first religion to be told from
the perspective of the victim
and so the relationship between
Christianity and Pagan religion is that
of a relationship of a vaccine an
original disease
of course the vaccine is efficacious
because of its proximity and not its
radical difference right this structure
is similar with a few tweaks and so for
Gerard Christianity is supposed to be a
myth vaccine it's supposed to take on
the same form as uh Pagan religion human
all human religion writ large but to
destroy religion from the inside for
Gerard Christianity is a religion to end
all religions yeah and so yeah go ahead
do you do you think that so this
exclusivity thesis let's call it do you
think he's right about that or could you
say I mean Buddhism
accomplishes something similar and
perhaps a few other religious
perspectives right what's your what's
your view on that so the first um thing
I'll say is I don't think Gerard is in
the business the the sort of uh Thomas
Aquinas business so to speak of trying
to prove God so I think he's really
giving you he he expects the best
outcome of his argumentation not to be
convincing proof but perhaps an openness
that is supposed to be capitalized on by
Grace or something like that right so so
this isn't supposed to be conclusive I
don't think
um with that said I would have to say no
um that I'm not very convinced by the
book
I'm compelled by the argument but I'm
not convinced let's put it that way
that's so good and and and I think
there's two uh sort of areas of attack
than you can give you know one area
attack is foreign foreign religions like
Buddhism that are very anti-sacrificial
in fact I wrote a whole manuscript uh
book length manuscript on the uh
similarity of of uh of Buddhism and
which is also of course skeptical of
desire and and Gerard and and I aim just
to show how
um Buddhism in some sense identified the
scapegoat mechanism
um in a perhaps even deeper uh uh
metaphysical way
um in the way that Gerard identified it
socially
the the other attack right is within the
Western Canon itself
in fact I would say the founding of the
western political uh sort of religion so
to speak in the western intellectual
religion in both Socrates and and Caesar
tell the story of an innocent victim
being murdered from the perspective of
the victim right that's what the phaedro
is that's what the apology is now I
actually think there's a you can see
that with the Socrates what's what's the
case for somebody like Caesar who well
it has power engages in a civil war you
know has has Primacy for a while
all I mean to say perhaps there is that
um ever since Caesar's death and
Augustus taking power Caesar was the
right was in the right in that whole
that whole perspective right and of
course that's political propaganda but
the story told is that Caesar was the
right it was the good guy and he was
wrongfully murdered so one would think
okay that that could also explode expose
group's Tendencies uh to uh you know to
to sort of reveal the scapular mechanism
now of course
I think the the the the Socrates case is
a much more compelling than the Caesar
case right and much more similar to the
price case and I think Detroit has a
somewhat interesting thing to say about
the Socrates case actually which I
perhaps intend to write a paper on but
at that point you're starting to do a
bit bit of mental gymnastics right and
and that's why it's only it's only
compelling and not convincing
well that's that's uh
yeah I mean
Socrates gets held up as this
philosophical hero I mean when you read
the apology you're like well clearly
this guy knew that um he's he's not
going to win so he's coming in to make a
bunch of points you know
um
I mean the Fatal yeah is is this sort of
inaugural document of the great
uh hero who explains you know in his
last day why we shouldn't be too upset
at the fact that he's gonna die you know
it doesn't doesn't completely convince
his friends because they're still crying
you know at the end
um and actually it's kind of funny this
is totally off topic but there's a
couple texts where every time I read
them I do end up getting weepy really
that Pedro is one of them yeah well
kamu's the the the uh the plague you
know at the end
um when I think it's is it Rue no it's
he's that's the doctor
um it's the it's the uh the guy who has
been working to to help everybody out he
finally succumbs to the plague right it
gets me every time but the Fatal does
too you know right right and I teach it
pretty frequently so
yeah all right you're thinking right
well it's funny because you think that
effect would wear off right you should
get
jaded or anticipated right yeah yeah but
I don't know it works each time for me
um
that's great maybe that maybe that's
more about my own idiosyncrasies but you
know
there we go well you know we have I
think three minutes left so is there
anything else that that we should we
should cover
um I think we'd be it'd be difficult for
us to pack in things I mean I'd like to
talk a lot more about original sin and
that idea but I don't know that we can
easily cover that ground uh so why don't
we take the time to just talk a little
bit about this uh this wonderful series
that you have out so where people can
find it I think the best thing people
can do is just type in uh Jonathan with
where it's it looks more like John
Nathan but I think even if they just
type in Jonathan limbo your YouTube
channel will come up right right so it
will come up we'll just type in
interpreting Gerard that's probably
easier to remember
um okay that'll lead you that'll lead
you to the the first lecture essentially
yeah I mean I wouldn't actually oh this
would be a good thing to ask you so
the the videos are not meant to be a
complete substitute for people reading
the text any any more than mine are
right but people do use them that way so
you've got more than 10 hours of really
high quality presentation about Gerard
that people if they want to know more
about the guy they will learn an awful
lot going through those those lectures
right so maybe that's the recommendation
for us to to close on I I hate to to
have people not read the text actually
let me ask you this so people want to
start with Gerard what book should they
read first
it's a great question I would say either
two two books one is if they're uh well
trained in the in in philosophy or a
related discipline I would go directly
into desire to see in the novel which is
um his sort of psychology and again for
Gerard I think psychology is first
philosophy and that's a great
introduction
um and or if if someone was more popular
reader or interested more in Gerard that
is much more accessible
um and you know here Gerard talk about
his opinion on current events like
climate change and Ai and stuff like
that
it's great book uh when these things
begin which is structured as an
interview okay
so anything else that you want to say
before we uh sign off them no this is uh
this has been such a such a pleasure
um come on again maybe maybe um some
some of those time when I have something
interesting to say but uh absolutely
it's been great Greg thanks so much for
having me well thanks so much for for
coming on and um yeah I look forward to
seeing what you what you bring out next
thank you